imagine three blindfolded scientists  chasing a lion the lion of everything  and as it runs past one of the  scientists grabs Estelle and says I've  got it it's one-dimensional and another  with the Lions left ear between thumb  and forefinger says hold on I've got it  if it's flat and wired it must be 2d and  the third to buy this time has caught up  and latched on to the Lions legs says  there's no way that eve of you can be  correct it's definitely 3d and then as  if by magic they're blind folds dissolve  and they see each other holding onto one  small part of the much larger hole all  correct not one of them is wrong yet no  one perspective is complete on its own  perception board and yours to encompass  all realities the theory of everything  definitely includes you  you